welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Samuel Jackson is back son because
the first trailer for secret Invasion
hit d23 harder than the president's
motorcade got hit by that missile sorry
Mr President and like a college kid
about to smoke the devil's lettuce for
the first time my goodness I have never
been more excited to be paranoid in my
life because anybody could be a scroll
because the scrolls are on a mission but
what exactly is this Mission anyway and
what do these pointy ear tricks actually
want that Nick Fury is keeping from them
well let's see if we can solve the
equation of the secret Invasion together
my nerve babies but first do not forget
to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you
can pick up our newest latest Obsession
shirt inspired by both She-Hulk and
House of the Dragon but they're not
going to be around forever so visit new
rockstarsmerch.com today alright so at
the very end of the secret Invasion
trailer audio of Nick Fury appears to
suggest that a rebel group of Scrolls
led by the scroll gravic as played by a
Kingsley Ben adir are on earth looking
for something particular that only one
Nicholas J Fury can give them to achieve
their goals this is my War alone
and I'm the last person standing between
them and what they really want but what
could this very secretive thing be well
let's take a look at what we know first
of all we know that Colonel James boom
looking for this road we'll be playing a
prominent role of the series a role that
Marvel Studios has revealed will
directly lead into his own solo MCU
series armor which itself is based on a
story of how Tony Stark's most dangerous
Iron Man tech secrets fall into the
wrong hands and also a series that has a
brand spanking new logo with the letter
o in that logo purposely seeming to be
modeled after an arc reactor which is
very fitting because Arc reactors are
vital to the operation of both Tony
Stark's Iron Man suits as well as
Roadies War Machine suits and an
invention that Tony Stark was able to
perfect with a new element thanks to
Howard Stark's path's work attempting to
unlock the sustainable energy secrets of
the Tesseract Howard said the Arc
Reactor was a stepping stone to
something greater something so big that
it was going to make the nuclear reactor
look like a AAA Battery Howard Stark did
this in conjunction with his former
partner Anton vancka whiplash's father
from Iron Man 2 who got deported to
Russia after trying to sell those secret
Tesseract secrets on the black market
the Russians would later send Anton
vanco to a siberian prison after he
failed to recreate a functioning Arc
Reactor for the country Anton saw it as
a way to get rich when your father found
out he had him deported and the Russians
found out he couldn't deliver they
shipped his ass off to Siberia and he
spent the next 20 years in a vodka fuel
rage and we also know from the Captain
Marvel film that the squirrels initially
came to Earth in search of Refuge from
the crease raw war with Cree scientist
Marvel providing this for all safe
passage aboard her completely hidden
spaceship laboratory high above Earth's
orbit while she continued to study the
Tesseract much like Howard Stark did and
one of the main places that Marvel
learned the most about the Tesseract is
of course when she was Undercover on
Earth as Dr Wendy Lawson at Shields
Project Pegasus facility Marvel was able
to construct a light speed engine that
she hoped to use to get her scroll
Refugee friends to safety somewhere far
away from the cree scroll War a mission
that Carol Danvers of course takes up at
the very end of Captain Marvel a light
speed engine that the cree wanted to use
to win the war but Marvel the person
decided to use to try to end the
conflict this isn't about fighting Wars
it's about ending them and because the
Tesseract was destroyed by The Mad Titan
in Avengers Infinity war and end game I
have a feeling that this Rebel faction
of Scrolls that seemed to be at odds
with talos's more peaceful band of
refugee Scrolls might be on earth
specifically to steal the Tesseract
research at the great minds of the
planet like Tony Stark Howard Stark
Marvel and Anton Banco have compiled and
the reason why Nick Fury could be the
only one that can stop them is because
Nick Fury's entire career as a spy has
revolved around an energy crisis in one
way or another specifically the legacy
of the Tesseract because out of everyone
on the planet Nick Fury has the most
extensive knowledge of Tesseract energy
sources and weapons so much so that
after Fury met Thor Loki and the
asgardians in 4-1 he was forced to face
the reality that the universe is filled
with threats that dwarf the strength of
humankind and so the world Security
Council losing faith and Fury's ability
to enact this Avenger initiative that he
keeps talking about authorized the
reactivation of Project Pegasus for the
specific purpose of harnessing the
energy potential of the Tesseract to
make handheld weapons in City decimating
nukes to fight these alien threats you
know just like Zola and the Red Skull
were trying to do during World War II
and they would call this Tesseract
weaponization phase two a project that
capped Bruce and Tony were less than
thrilled to find out about in Avengers
one we gathered everything related to
the Tesseract this does not mean sorry
Nick what were you lying
I was wrong director and since we know
that one of these wmds were responsible
for destroying the chittari hive mind
warship with little guidance from Iron
Man I have a strong inkling that
Graphics Rebel faction of skrulls want a
piece of that Tesseract technology to
avenge all the Scrolls that the cree
killed when their Homeworld was
destroyed and Nick Fury is the key to
all of that because like you said in the
trailer this was always his war that
he's been preparing for for his entire
career with his research on the
Tesseract and the Scrolls will stop at
nothing to mine all of that Tesseract
intelligence from his mind using that
same memory machine that they used on
Captain Marvel so they can create the
nukes in Lightspeed engines that can
help them become a dominating force in
the universe I sincerely believe that
this is the significance of this shot of
a Russian laboratory with the words no
entry for unauthorized people on the
door we can see a circular device with
arch supports being constructed I have a
feeling that this is the Russian
laboratory that Anton vanco was using to
attempt to recreate the Arc Reactor that
both him and Howard's dark designed for
Russia as those Arch beams in the
trailer resemble those Arch beams that
surround Stark Industries reactor in
Iron Man 1. but though Anton ultimately
failed in his attempt I suspect that his
research would nonetheless be extremely
valuable to this faction of Rebel
Scrolls in a lot easier to obtain
because it's not in New York surrounded
by a bunch of superheroes and the dodc
and all these entities I believe the end
of secret Invasion will naturally lead
into armor words because the invasion
will lead to all of Stark's Tesseract
research falling into the wrong hands
forcing Roadie to clean up the mess the
squirrels made in secret invasion in his
own armor Wars sequel series but yeah
that's what I think the scrolls are
after in secret Invasion these bad
squirrels just want the cree Empire to
suffer for what they've done to their
people by establishing Earth as a new
home while they steal the very research
and technology that made Planet c53
ready for a higher form of War because
gravic is not as soft as Talos he is
ready to do whatever it takes thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at massertainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
the social media and of course do not
forget to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
to pick up our newest latest Obsession
Church inspired by both She-Hulk and
House of the Dragon they're not gonna
last forever so pick them up today thank
you again for watching this video and
for spending time with me I love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye
[Music]